[Applause]
welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio and a question that has
emerged in recent days peter and rodney
harrison was banging this one
aggressively on sunday night prior to
the colts chiefs game christie mccaffrey
panthers running back leading the league
in rushing on pace to set the single
season yards from scrimmage record
is he a viable mvp candidate or are we
stuck in this mode where it just goes to
a great quarterback from a team that has
a great record
mike if this were a league of kyle
allen's right now
if this were a league of chase daniels
right now that you know where we weren't
having some great quarterback
performances
uh i would say yeah this you know
christian mccaffrey might be in the lead
for the mvp
but not saying that he won't be a
significant contender because i think he
will be if he keeps playing like this
and he keeps lifting
uh you know the carolina panthers to
contention post cam newton but i do
think right now that patrick mahomes
is the leader in the clubhouse he
doesn't have it won but i think behind
patrick mahomes is russell wilson and
christian mccaffrey those are the two
prime contenders for the number one uh
deal right now and mike i banged this
drum for years speaking of banging the
drums i don't like the way that the mvp
in the nfl is chosen in baseball you
pick one through ten and in football
in in voting conducted by the associated
press you pick one player and so you
might say boy i'll tell you what it's
really close between
this guy and that guy i'd really like to
give mccaffrey some credit for this well
you can't
if you if you think that patrick mahomes
or russell wilson is the mvp of the
league you got to pick him now in the
past twice i have voted to split my vote
uh at the top uh
you know what they for the mvp
uh and i've voted i don't know for maybe
25 years
but i think right now if the season
ended today
i would vote for uh i'd vote for patrick
mahomes
and i agree with you completely the
minimum needs to be first place second
place third place and a weighted voting
system where the points are collected
and you figure out the winner that way
and and i think that a non-quarterback
only has a realistic chance to win when
the non-quarterback does something
historic we saw adrian peterson in 2012
get very close to eric dickerson's
single season rushing record that helped
him edge out peyton manning in his first
year back from the neck problems so you
need something like that to supplant the
top quarterback especially in light of
the way patrick mahomes has played now
he had a down game on sunday against the
colts but i expect him to bounce back
russell wilson has been spectacular as
well and i think that's what makes it
harder for a non-quarterback as you said
it is a golden age of quarterbacks there
are so many great quarterbacks that you
have to do something that somehow
supersedes them and i don't see any of
these other non-quarterbacks doing it
it's kind of funny we talk about a down
game from holmes he threw for over 300
without throwing an interception oh my
god what a bad game
right with patrick holmes of course yeah
yep but but still
a down game for him is a pretty good
game for any quarterback in the nfl so
he's had four transcendent games really
collectively and one mad game
i still think he's number one another
guy to keep an eye on and this will make
chris sims very happy if he sees this
video we have to keep an eye on aaron
rodgers he's been spectacular the past
couple of weeks he's learning that
offense i was very impressed by what
they were able to do against the cowboys
without devante adams available to them
and aaron rodgers one of the older guys
in the mix can still run the ball when
he needs to throws the ball incredibly
well and if the packers keep winning
football games i really do feel like
that's a huge factor when you have that
one seed that helps boost the guys
candidacy when it's time to figure out
the votes peter
there's no question about it but
aaron rodgers has had the benefit of a
great pass rush and a better defense i
think than either patrick mahomes or
russell wilson has had so far
all right you can check out more pft ot
on yahoo sports videos throughout the
2019 nfl season we'll see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports